This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This week we're going to tell you the story of a woman who ran a psychological experiment on herself. We look at the science of compassion and why being kind to others can make a big difference in your own life. It's easy to say, I can't make a difference, but everyone can make a difference. I want to tell you the story about a woman named Kelly Gillespie. She's in her early 40s, lives in London, and a couple of years ago, she took a psychology class. The class was online hosted by the education platform Coursera, and it was taught by Scott Klaus. He's a psychologist at Wesleyan University. And then my life changed after doing professor's course. And now I'm studying to be a psychotherapist and counselor.
这里是隐藏的大脑，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。本周我们将为您讲述一个女人对自己进行心理学实验的故事。我们探讨了同情心的科学，以及为什么对他人善良会在你自己的生活中产生重大影响。人们常说，我无法改变什么，但每个人都能有所作为。我想给你们讲一个名叫凯利·吉勒平的女性的故事。她四十出头，住在伦敦，几年前，她上了一门心理学课程。这门课是在线进行的，由教育平台Coursera托管，授课老师是斯科特·克劳斯。他是卫斯理大学的心理学家。教授的课程结束后，我的生活发生了改变。现在我正在学习成为一名心理治疗师和辅导员。
Kelly learned several psychological concepts in the class. One is called the norm of reciprocity. If you're nice to someone or you open up to them, they are likely to do the same with you. She also learned about the power of empathy. When you put yourself in someone else's shoes, it profoundly changes the relationship that you have with them.
凯利在课堂上学到了几个心理学概念。其中一个是所谓的互惠规范。如果你对某人好或者向他们敞开心扉，他们很可能也会对你做出同样的举动。她还了解到了同理心的力量。当你设身处地为他人着想时，它会深刻地改变你与他们之间的关系。
Now lots of people learn about ideas and psychology, but Kelly did something unusual. She took what she had learned in the class and she applied it in her own life. As well I also like books and novels so I spend a lot of time at the British Library at King's Course. My husband works just on the corner from there, so every Friday afternoon I would meet him out of work after I'd been at the British Library of the East searching. I would finish about four o'clock, he would finish about six o'clock, so I'd take a couple of hours to spend, sometimes I'd go to the welcome, sometimes I'd just sit and have a coffee and watch people walking by and always the same young guy and always smiling despite not having anywhere to live or not having a job or any money but he was always so pleasant and it started off simply me giving him what's their change I had but it
很多人学习心理学理念，但凯利做了一件不寻常的事。她把课堂上学到的东西应用到了自己的生活中。同时我也喜欢书和小说，所以我花了很多时间在大英图书馆金斯柯斯分馆。我丈夫的工作地点就在那里的拐角处，所以每周五下午，我在大英图书馆查阅完资料后，都会去那里接他下班。我大约四点结束，他大约六点结束，所以我会有几个小时的空闲时间，有时我会去维康博物馆，有时我只是坐着喝杯咖啡，看着行人来来往往。总有同一个年轻小伙子，总是面带微笑，尽管无家可归，没有工作也没有钱，但他总是那么亲切。一开始只是我把身上的零钱给他，但
went on for a couple of months and I got to know him a little bit and know what had happened to make him leave home and come to London. Kelly learned his name was Simon. She asked him if he would sit down with her for a cup of coffee. He was just walking past on the other side of the road. I think he walked up and down to a court of the day and on a night he would get onto the night buses because he had nowhere to sleep. He would just get on the night bus and travel down and down and down until six o'clock in the morning hoping to sleep, hoping to not get attacked
这种情况持续了几个月，我稍微了解了他一点，也知道了是什么让他离开家来到伦敦。凯利得知他的名字叫西蒙。她问他愿不愿意和她坐下来喝杯咖啡。他当时正从马路对面走过。我想他一天里会来来回回走上好几趟，到了晚上，他就坐夜班公交车，因为他无处安睡。他就会一直坐着夜班公交车，一路向下坐，直到清晨六点，希望能睡一会儿，希望能不被袭击
by the junks and the people that use the night buses in London. To make him feel comfortable, I told him a little bit about my life. I told him I was waiting for a husband. I told him how long we'd been together, things like that. And I think by sharing a little bit of my life, I made him more confident to talk about his life. And I found out, I mean, he wasn't from far away from London, just incant on the southeast coast, so only, and now with away from London, way to go up.
被伦敦夜班公交车上的瘾君子和那些人袭击。为了让他感到舒适，我向他透露了一点我生活的情况。我告诉他我在等丈夫。我告诉他我们在一起多久了，诸如此类的事情。我想通过分享我生活的一小部分，我让他更有信心谈论他的人生。我发现，我的意思是，他离伦敦并不远，就在东南海岸的肯特郡，所以离伦敦只有一段距离，可以回去。
And what's going through your head about what you can see or do that would be helpful? He can't mention how much he missed his mum, how much he was so close to his mum and that's a relationship that should never be damaged or taken apart so I think that led to me asking him, would he like to speak to his mum? Because my mum died ten years ago and if someone said to me now you can speak to your mum, I would bite their hand off. So I just asked him if he wanted to speak to his mum and he said yeah he never had a problem with his mum it was because of his father that he left home and he loved his mum very much and I just thought if he left someone so much he shouldn't be so distant from them.
你脑海中在想些什么关于你能看到或做些什么才会有帮助的事情呢？他情不自禁地提到他是多么想念他的妈妈，他是多么和妈妈亲近，那是一段永远不应该被破坏或拆散的关系，所以我想这促使我问他，他想不想和妈妈通电话？因为我妈妈十年前去世了，如果现在有人对我说你可以和你妈妈说话，我会毫不犹豫地答应。所以我只是问他想不想和妈妈通话，他说他愿意，他跟妈妈从来没有什么问题，是因为父亲他才离家出走的，他非常爱他的妈妈，我当时就想，如果他那么爱一个人，他就不应该和他们这么疏远。
I just thought if he loves someone so much he shouldn't be so distant from them. He has nothing to lose. Can you remember your home phone number? Of course everyone remembers their home phone number. You have nothing to lose. Cos you have nothing. So let's just give it a go and see what happens. He didn't want to at first, he didn't want to speak to her, but eventually I found his mum and I said, um, I'm a friend of Simon's. She started crying immediately because she had no room in the house. She didn't know if he was alive or dead. And it was, it was... Immediately, she was so emotional.
我当时就想，如果他那么爱一个人，就不应该和他们这么疏远。他没有什么可失去的。你还记得家里的电话号码吗？当然每个人都记得家里的电话号码。你没有什么好失去的。因为你一无所有。所以我们就试一试，看看会发生什么。他一开始不愿意，他不想跟她说话，但最终我找到了他妈妈，我说，嗯，我是西蒙的朋友。她立刻哭了起来，因为家里没有他的音讯。她不知道他是死是活。那种情绪……刹那间，她情绪激动万分。
And at that moment I thought, okay, I'm just going to pass the phone over and let them talk. They talked for about 10 minutes, 15 minutes. It was quite beautiful to watch because he started off not knowing what to say and being very guarded and defensive. That all broke down within five minutes. He didn't tell them that he was homeless. He didn't mention that at all. He just had been living in London. Everything's okay. I'm still alive. You never mentioned this situation at all though. And once the conversation was over, what
就在那一刻，我心想，好吧，我把电话递过去让他们聊吧。他们聊了大约10分钟、15分钟。看着这一幕真的很美妙，因为他一开始不知道该说什么，而且防备心很重。这一切在五分钟内就瓦解了。他没有告诉他们他无家可归。他根本没提这件事。他只是说一直在伦敦生活。一切都好。我还活着。不过你从来没提过这处境。对话结束后，你
did you say to him and how do things go from there? I got a little bit bossy actually and I said okay, this isn't going to solve itself. So we went to Victoria, coach station and I said if you don't do this, this is the best chance you're going to have of going back home. Seeing your mum. And putting a medic on the next bus to go back to South End. And that's the last I saw him. He got on the bus and away he went. In terms of what you've done with Sinc Simon, has it changed your behavior? Have you always been somebody who goes up to homeless people and helps them? Or have you actually become
对他说什么了，事情后来怎么样了？其实我当时变得有点霸道，我说好吧，这事不会自己解决的。于是我们去了维多利亚长途汽车站，我说如果你不这样做，这就是你回家的最好机会。去见你妈妈。我把他送上了回绍森德的下一班车。那是我最后一次见到他。他上了车，然后就走了。就你对西蒙所做的事情而言，它改变了你的行为吗？你一向都是那种会主动接近无家可归的人并给予帮助的人吗？还是说你实际上变得
more proactive? Because you sort of say, I realized that I actually can make a difference and maybe I can make a difference on a mass scale, but I certainly made a difference in one person's life and that teaches me that I could make difference in other people's lives too. I think that doing the course with Professor Bliss most definitely opened my eyes to the reasons why people don't do something to help. And I can remember he told us this wonderful story as part of the course, which was told originally I think by Kenyan and Vythermental activist called Wagarvi Mutamati, and it's a story of a hummingbird in a forest that's being consumed by a wildfire, and all the animals in the forest come out and they're transfixed as they watch the forest burning, and they
更加积极主动了？因为你某种程度上会说，我意识到我其实可以有所作为，也许我能在宏大的规模上产生影响，但我确实在一个人的生活中产生了影响，这教会了我，我也能在其他人的生活中产生影响。我觉得和布利斯教授一起上课绝对开阔了我的眼界，让我明白了人们为什么不愿采取行动去帮助他人。我记得他在课上给我们讲过一个美妙的故事，这个故事最初好像是由一位肯尼亚环保活动家旺加里·马塔伊讲述的，讲的是一只蜂鸟在一片被野火吞噬的森林里，森林里的所有动物都跑出来，目瞪口呆地看着森林燃烧，它们
feel very overwhelmed and very powerless, except this one little hummingbird that says I'm going to do something about this fire. And the vetor police told us this story about all the animals laughing at this little hummingbird as it flew backwards and forwards from the nearer stream with one drop of water that are timed to put out the fire, but at least it was doing something and it was doing the best it can. And I think that's something that the baby, the baby hit a tune note with me, but it's easy to say I can't make a difference, but everyone can make a difference. Coming up next, the person whom Kelly says changed her life, her teacher, psychologist Scott Plouse of Wesleyan University.
感到非常无力和无能为力，除了这只小蜂鸟，它说我要为这场火做点什么。维特·普利斯给我们讲了这个故事，讲的是所有动物都嘲笑这只小蜂鸟，因为它一次次从附近的溪流飞来飞去，嘴里衔着一滴水试图扑灭大火，但它至少在做些什么，在尽它最大的努力。我想这件事深深触动了我，人们很容易说我无能为力，但每个人都能有所作为。接下来出场的是凯利所说改变了她一生的人——她的老师，卫斯理大学的心理学家斯科特·普劳斯。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. I first met Scott many years ago. He's a very smart guy. But the thing that leaps out when you meet him is that he's a really nice guy. Actually scratch that. Nice doesn't cut it. Scott radiates kindness. The class where Scott connected with Kelly was an online class.
这里是隐藏的大脑，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。我很多年前第一次见到斯科特。他是个非常聪明的人。但当你见到他时，最显眼的特质是他人真的很好。其实算了吧。说人好根本不足以形容。斯科特浑身散发着善良。斯科特与凯利结缘的那门课是一门在线课程。
Believe it or not, more than 250,000 students from around the world signed up for the class. And at the end of it, Scott gave Kelly and his other students an assignment. It was called the day of compassion. Students had to spend one day being deliberately kind and generous toward others. Scott asked them to notice how these actions changed the way they felt about themselves. I asked Scott to tell me what students find when they do this. Students often report that it's transformative, that they're really surprised at the reaction, that people are so overwhelmingly positive that it starts to feed on itself. And by the end of the day they report
信不信由你，来自世界各地的25万多名学生注册了这门课程。在课程结束时，斯科特给凯利和其他学生布置了一项作业。这被称为同情心日。学生们必须花一天时间，刻意对他人表现出善良和慷慨。斯科特要求他们注意这些行动如何改变了他们对自己的看法。我请斯科特告诉我，学生们在做这件事时发现了什么。学生们经常反映说这是具有变革性的，他们对反应感到非常惊讶，人们的反应是如此压倒性地积极，以至于它开始形成良性循环。到了傍晚，他们反映说
that this is a different side of me that I didn't recognize on itself. And by the end of the day, they report that this is a different side of me that I didn't recognize was there. And is that because they are behaving differently, or other people are behaving differently, what's the cause, what's driving this change? Oftentimes, it seems that compassion is contagious. We've talked about pain and forward, the idea that if you do something good for another person, that that gives the other person a kind of lift, and then that person in turn will do something for somebody else, and it sets off a kind of chain reaction. So it's not just find the one dramatic thing that you can do in the day that can change the life of someone else.
这是我以前没有意识到的自己的另一面。到了傍晚，他们反映说这是我以前没有意识到的自己的另一面。这是因为他们的行为不同了，还是其他人表现不同了，原因是什么，是什么在推动这种变化？通常情况下，同情心似乎是会传染的。我们讨论过“将爱传递下去”这个概念，即如果你为另一个人做了好事，这会给对方带来一种振奋，然后那个人反过来又会为其他人做点什么，从而引发一种连锁反应。所以，不只是要在一天里找到一件你可以做的戏剧性的事情去改变另一个人的生活。
You're actually asking people to change the way they live that day. That's right. And you know Martin Luther King Jr. had a wonderful quote as well about the effect that you have just in eating breakfast, the number of lives that you touch, where the cereal comes from, where the packaging comes from, who brought the cereal to you, where did the milk come from, and so on. And before you know it, you've touched thousands of lives without even realizing it. So the students are asked to look deeply, to think deeply about their life choices, their behaviors, and to think about it specifically in terms of compassion.
你其实是在要求人们改变他们那一天的生活方式。没错。你知道马丁·路德·金也说过一句精彩的名言，关于你仅仅在吃早餐时产生的深远影响，你触及了多少人的生活，麦片来自哪里，包装来自哪里，是谁把麦片带给你的，牛奶来自哪里，诸如此类。不知不觉中，你在甚至没有意识到的情况下已经触动了成千上万人的生命。所以学生们被要求深入观察，深入思考他们的人生选择、行为，并具体从同情心的角度去思考。
So, when you're eating your cereal, even if you know that these thousands of people have touched your cereal, how do you act compassionately to what all of them? Well, in some cases you might be thinking about people who are working under unfair labor conditions. You might be thinking, if I throw away this food, what else am I throwing away? You might think about when you drive to work, could you be bicycling, could you be walking, what consequences are there for other people? So there are many, many different connections that we normally don't have time to think about. And in this assignment, I ask students to simply slow down and think about those connections.
所以，当你吃麦片时，即使你知道这成千上万的人触碰过你的麦片，你该如何对所有这些人表现出同情呢？嗯，在某些情况下，你可能会想到那些在不公平劳动条件下工作的人。你可能会想，如果我扔掉这些食物，我还扔掉了什么别的东西？你可能会想，当你开车上班时，你本可以骑自行车，本可以步行，这对其他人会产生什么后果？所以有许许多多不同的联系，我们通常没有时间去思考。在这项作业中，我要求学生们放慢脚步，简单地思考这些联系。
You know, it's interesting when we actually start thinking about this in great detail, we often realize then that we are making choices that even though we think of ourselves as being good people, those choices are often unsupportable by the values that we claim to have. In my book, I talk about the idea that I was discussing the role that childhood vaccines play in saving children's lives in many parts of the world and how for $200, you could probably save a child's life in a poor country by making sure that she has access to just a suite of childhood vaccines. And when I gave my daughter a birthday party, this was a couple years ago, and the birthday party cost $200 or $250. I had a moment where I stopped and said, I'm spending $250 on my child's birthday party,
你知道，很有意思的是，当我们开始非常详细地思考这一点时，我们常常会意识到，我们正在做出这样的选择：尽管我们认为自己是好人，但这些选择往往无法支撑我们宣称拥有的价值观。在我的书中，我谈到了这样一个观点：我曾讨论过儿童疫苗在世界许多地方拯救儿童生命方面所起的作用，以及如何通过200美元，你就可以为一个贫穷国家的儿童提供一套全面的儿童疫苗，从而拯救她的生命。当我给女儿办生日派对时，这是几年前的事了，生日派对花费了200或250美元。我当时停顿了一下心想，我在我孩子的生日派对上花掉了250美元，
and the same $250 could save the life of a child halfway around the world. Now how is it possible that one child's birthday party could be more important than another child's life? And I felt like a terrible human being. Well, I'm sorry you feel terrible about that, but at least having a level of awareness, I think, can be a positive thing. The Princeton philosopher, Peter Singer,
而同样的250美元却可以拯救世界另一端一个孩子的生命。现在，怎么可能一个孩子的生日派对会比另一个孩子的生命更重要呢？我觉得自己是一个糟糕透顶的人。好吧，很抱歉你为此感到糟糕，但至少具备一定程度的意识，我认为，可以是一件积极的事情。普林斯顿大学哲学家彼得·辛格
has a great example of this. He talks about somebody who's walking past some water and sees a child drowning. And this person happens to be in very fancy clothes, let's say an armani suit or some very expensive shoes. And the question is, if you're the only one there and the only one capable of saving the child and there's no time to spare,
有一个极佳的例子。他谈到有人走过一些水域，看到一个孩子快要溺水了。这个人碰巧穿着非常考究的衣服，比方说阿玛尼西装或非常昂贵的鞋子。问题是，如果你是那里唯一的人，也是唯一有能力拯救这个孩子且时间紧迫的人，
should you, in fact, ruin your suit, should you ruin your shoes and save the life? Let's say that you would lose $200 doing that. And almost everybody would say, of course, the child's life is worth more than the $200. And then Peter Singer turns around and says, well, what if we could demonstrate that there's a child's life halfway around the world and that $200 would be sufficient to save that life? Why aren't you spending the $200? And of course, the question is lots of us
你实际上应该毁掉你的西装，应该毁掉你的鞋子去救命吗？假设你这样做会损失200美元。几乎所有人都会说，当然，孩子的生命比200美元更有价值。接着彼得·辛格话锋一转说道，那么，如果我们能证明世界另一端有一个孩子的生命，而200美元就足以拯救那个生命呢？你为什么不花这200美元？当然，问题在于我们中的许多人
don't, the child and the pond who's drowning, feels visceral to us and feels like our responsibility in ways that the child halfway around the world does not feel like our responsibility. That's exactly right. There's an immediacy there. There's a vividness and there's different consequences when you see somebody personally in need rather than having somebody be abstract and remote,
不会这样做。池塘里溺水的孩子对我们来说是直观的，感觉是我们的责任，而世界另一端那个遥远的孩子则感觉不是我们的责任。完全正确。其中有一种即时性。有一种生动性，当你亲眼看到某人有需求时，与看到某人是抽象而遥远的时，会产生不同的后果，
and people will say to themselves, well, maybe that's true, but there are so many children in need if I gave each one $200, I would be left in poverty. I can't possibly do that. And this is where psychology comes in. We tell ourselves stories about why it's okay not to help. Why it's okay not to help once. And we say, well, because if I then did once, I would have to do a hundred, and I couldn't possibly do that. But in fact, sometimes you can do one,
人们会对自己说，好吧，也许这是真的，但有那么多需要帮助的孩子，如果我给每个人200美元，我就会陷入贫困。我绝对做不到这一点。这就是心理学发挥作用的地方。我们给自己编造各种理由，解释为什么不帮忙是可以的。为什么不帮忙一次是可以的。我们会说，好吧，因为如果我做了这一次，我就得做一百次，而我根本做不到。但实际上，有时你可以做一次，
and one is better than zero. That's Social Psychologist Scott Plouse from Wesleyan University. What would you do if you had to spend one day beaming compassion into the world? It could be something small, acknowledging a stranger. It could be something big, changing the direction of another person's life. Please try it and tell us what you found. You can find us on Facebook at Hidden Brain or send us an email at hiddenbrainatnpr.org.
而且做一次总比一次都不做好。这是来自卫斯理大学的社会心理学家斯科特·普劳斯。如果你必须花一天时间向世界播撒同情心，你会怎么做？这可能是一件小事，向陌生人致意。这也可能是一件大事，改变另一个人的人生方向。请尝试一下，并告诉我们你的发现。你可以在Facebook上通过Hidden Brain找到我们，或者发邮件至hiddenbrainatnpr.org。
A small update, Kelly spends lots of time thinking about psychology and mental health in her work at the Bethlehem Museum of the Mind. Scott has a new version of his online course, you can find it on Coursera. It still ends with a day of compassion. This episode was produced by Kara McGurk-Allison and Maggie Pennman. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Parts Shah, Reena Cohen, Thomas Liu, Laura Correll and Kimela Vargas Restrepo. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle.
一个小近况，凯利在伯利恒心灵博物馆的工作中，花了很多时间思考心理学和心理健康。斯科特推出了他在线课程的新版本，你可以在Coursera上找到它。它依然以“同情心日”作为结尾。本期节目由卡拉·麦格克-阿利森和玛吉·彭曼制作。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、帕特·沙阿、丽娜·科恩、托马斯·刘、劳拉·科雷尔和基梅拉·瓦尔加斯·雷斯特雷波。我们的监管制片人是塔拉·博伊尔。
Our Ronsang hero this week is Vanessa Castillo. Vanessa is an administrative assistant at NPR and she helps us with pretty much everything. Paying freelance producers, ordering office supplies, sorting through all the details that help NPR's podcasts run smoothly. Vanessa has been at NPR only a short time and we are hard pressed to know how we survived before she came. Thanks Vanessa.
我们本周的无名英雄是凡妮莎·卡斯蒂略。凡妮莎是NPR的行政助理，她几乎在所有事情上都给予我们帮助。支付自由制片人的报酬，订购办公用品，梳理帮助NPR播客顺利运行的所有细节。凡妮莎在NPR工作的时间很短，我们很难想象在她来之前我们是怎么熬过来的。谢谢你，凡妮莎。
You can find more Hidden Brain on Facebook and Twitter. If you like the show, please tell one friend about a Hidden Brain episode that made an impression on you. I'm Shankar Vedantam, see you next week. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到更多《隐藏的大脑》。如果你喜欢这个节目，请向一位朋友推荐一期让你印象深刻的《隐藏的大脑》节目。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，下周见。目前本期节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。